alright hey everyone morning and welcome
back so what I'd like to do today is
continue our discussion of naive Bayes
and in particular would describe how to
use naive Bayes generative learning
algorithm to build a spam classifier
that will almost work right and and so
today you see how the paths moving is
one other idea you need to add to the
naive Bayes algorithm we described on
Monday to really make it work for say
email spam constellation or for text
oxidation and then we'll talk about a
different version of naive Bayes there's
even better than the one we've been
discussing so far it's a little bit
about advice for applying machine
learning algorithms so this will be
useful to you as you get started on your
system across projects as well this is
strategy for how to choose an algorithm
and what to do first what to do second
and then we'll start with intro to
support so to recap the naive Bayes
algorithm is a generative learning
algorithm in which given a piece of
email or Twitter message or some piece
of text psycho dictionary and put in
zeros and ones depending on whether
different words appear in a particular
email and so this becomes your feature
representation for say an email that
you're trying to classify as spam on all
spam so using the indicator function
notation XJ I've been trying to use a
subscript J not consistently to denote
the indexes and features and I to invest
in training examples but we'll see I'm
not going
mrs. J is whether or not an indicator
for where the word J appears in an email
and so to build a generative model for
this we need to model these two terms P
of x given Y and PF y so Gaussian to
strengthen Alice's models these two
terms with a Gaussian and a Bernoulli
respectively and naive Bayes uses a
different model and with naive based in
particular P of X given Y is modeled as
a product of the conditional
probabilities of the new features given
the class label Y and so the parameters
the naive Bayes model are Phi subscript
Y is the class prior what's the chance
that Y is equal to one before you've
seen any features as well as Phi
subscript J given y equals 0 which is a
chance of that word appearing in a
non-spam as was Phi subscript J given y
equals 1 which is the chance event worth
that were appearing in spam email okay
and so if you derive the maximum
likelihood estimates you will find that
the maximum likelihood estimator you
know Phi Y right just a fraction of
training examples that was equal to spam
and this is just the indicator function
notation way of writing with all of your
emails with label y equals zero and
counter my fraction of them did this
feature X J appeared did this word x JM
here and then finally a prediction time
you will calculate P of Y given X this
is kind of according to Bayes rule
all right so it turns out this algorithm
will almost work and here's where it
breaks down which is um you know so
actually every year there are some CST
realized some machine learning students
or do a class project and some people
end up submitting this to an academic
conference right some some actually some
some 169 class projects get submitted
gos conference papers pretty much every
year one of the top machine learning
conferences is the conference nibs name
stands the neural information processing
systems and let's say that in your
dictionary you know you have 10,000
words in your dictionary let's say that
the nibs conference the word nibs
corresponds to word number 6 0 17 right
in your you know 10,000 word dictionary
but up until now presumably you've not
had a lot of emails from your friends
asking hey do you want some of the paper
to the nibs conference or not and so if
you use your current you know email set
of emails to find these maximum
likelihood estimate the parameters you
will probably estimate that probability
of seeing this word given that it's spam
email it's probably 0 right 0 over the
number of examples that you've labeled
as down email so if you clean up this
model using your personal email probably
none of the emails you've received for
the last few months had the word nips in
it maybe and so if you plug in this form
for the master likely estimate the
numerator 0 and so you ask me that this
probably is 0 and then similarly this is
also 0 over you know the number of non
staff
right so that's what this just this
formula right and statistically is just
a bad idea to say that the chance of
something is zero just because you
haven't seen it yet and where this will
cause the naive Bayes Outland to break
down is if you use these as estimates of
the parameters so this is your estimate
parameter Phi subscript six zero one
seven given y equals one this is five
such of 6001 seven given y equals zero
yes
and if you ever calculate this
probability that is equal to a product
from I equals 1 through n less you have
10,000 words appear to make us I equals
1 o P of X i given the y right and so if
you train your sound classifier on the
email you've gotten up until today
and then after cs2 to 89 your project
teammates saying it starts engine email
saying hey you know we like the class
project shall we consists of letting
this class project to the news
conference news conference deadlines you
know sort of May or June those years so
you know finish the house projects this
December work on this some more very
gently very March April next year and
then maybe submit to the conference May
or June of 2019 do you start getting
emails on your fancy let's submit our
papers in its conference then when you
start to see the word nips in your email
maybe in March of next year this product
of probabilities will have a 0 in it and
so this thing that the circle will
evaluate to zero because you're
multiplying a lot numbers 1 which is 0
and in the same way this well this is
also 0 right and this is also 0 because
there'll be that one term bring that
product over there and so what that
means is if you train the spam
classifier today using all the data you
have in your email inbox so far and if
tomorrow
you know or two months from now whatever
the first time you get an email from
your teammates that has the word nips in
it your spam classifier will estimate
this probability as zero over zero plus
zero okay
now apart from the divide by zero error
it turns out that this is just a bad
idea right to estimate the probably of
something as zero just because you have
not seen it once yet right so what I
want to do is describe to you
Laplace smoothing which is a technique
that helps address this problem
okay and let's let's uh in order to
motivate Laplace moving let me use a let
me use a different example for now let's
see all right so you know several years
ago this is this is older data but
several years ago so then put a sign ID
based on top of the pops movie no come
back to pile up house routine my base so
several years ago I was tracking their
progress of the Stanford football team
there's a few years ago now but that
year on 9/12
a football team played to Wake Forest
you know I think these are all the all
the state games we played that year
right and we did not win that game then
on Jen Jen we played Oregon State and we
did not win that game
and the question is these are audio way
games almost all the other state games
we played that yeah and so via the you
know Stanford forgot his biggest fan he
followed into every single out-of-state
game and watch all these games the
question is after this unfortunate
shriek when you go on the accession game
when you as if you follow them to their
over Homer game what's your estimate of
their chance of their winning or losing
now if use maximum likelihood so let's
say this is the variable X you would
estimate the probability of their
winning well that's one life because
really count up the number of wins right
and divide that by the number of wins
plus the number of losses and so in this
case you estimate this as 0 divided by
number of wins of 0 number of losses is
4 right which is equal to 0 ok um that's
kind of mean right they lost 4 games but
you say no the Chancellor that they're
winning is 0 absolute certain to you and
then justice lee this is not this is not
a good idea and so what the process
moving what we're going to do is imagine
that we saw the positive outcomes the
number of wins you know just add one to
the number of wins we actually saw and
also the number of losses at 1 right so
if you actually saw 0 wins
pretend you saw one that we saw four
losses pretend you saw one more than you
actually saw and so the plus moving
gonna end up adding 1 to the numerator
and adding 2 to the denominator and so
this ends up being 1 over 6 and that's
actually a more reasonable well maybe
maybe this is a more reasonable estimate
for the chance of that
or losing the next game and there's
actually a certain set of circumstances
under which there's an optimal estimate
so I didn't just make the Sabbath in
there but Laplace you know ancient that
well-known very influential
mathematician he was actually I spent
the chance of the Sun rising the next
day and the reasoning was well we've
seen the Sun Rise a lot of times and so
but but that doesn't mean we should be
absolutely certain the Sun will still
rise tomorrow right and so his reasoning
was well we've seen the Sun Rise 10,000
times you know we can be really certain
the Sun will rise again tomorrow but
maybe not absolutely certain because
maybe something will go wrong
who knows what happened this galaxy and
so his reasoning was he derived the
optimal way of estimating you know
really the chance the Sun will rise
tomorrow and this is actually an optimal
estimate under I'll say I'll save the
sail assumptions we don't need to worry
about it but the sense of they assumed
that you are Bayesian with a uniform
Bayesian prior on the chance of the Sun
rising tomorrow so if the chance of Sun
rising tomorrow is uniformly distributed
you're in the unit interval anywhere
from 0 to 1 then after the set of
observations of this coin toss of
whether the Sun rises this is actually
based in optimist myth of the chosen Sun
rising tomorrow ok if you don't stand
which is in the last 30 seconds don't
worry about it this is taught in sort of
Bayesian statistics that bounds Bayesian
statistics classes but mechanically what
you should do is uh take this formula
and add 1 to the number of counts you
actually saw for each of the possible
outcomes and more generally if Y excuse
me if if you're estimating probabilities
for a way random variable then you
estimate the chance of X being I to be
equal to you
so that's the maximum likelihood
estimate and for Laplace moving you'd
add one to the numerator and add K to
the denominator so for naive Bayes the
way the small modifies your premises
I'm just going to copy over right so
that's the max or likely estimate and
with the pasta thing you add one to the
numerator and add two to the denominator
and this means they us mr. probabilities
probably is they're never exactly zero
or exactly one which takes away that
problem of field is zero over zero and
so the employers algorithm yeah it's not
there's not like a great spam classifier
but it's not terrible either and one
nice thing about this algorithm is is so
simple right estimated parameters is
just counting can be done you know very
efficiently right just just by counting
and then classification time is just
multiply a bunch of properties together
this very competition efficient
algorithm all right any questions about
this
yeah
oh sorry this why oh yes thank you all
right
oh by the way I I was actually falling
inside the football team that year so
okay I love a football team they're
doing much better now because a few
years ago all right
um so um in Indy example of Tulsa fell
so far the features were binary valued
and so my quick generalization when the
features are multinomial value then the
generalization actually here's one
example we talked about predicting
housing prices right that was a very
first moving example let's say you have
a classification problem instead which
is your listing house u.s. Smith once
the chance that this house would be so
weird in the next 30 days so it's a
classification problem so if one of the
features is the size of the house X
right then one way to turn the feature
into this speaker would be to choose a
few buckets so if the size is less than
400 square feet versus you know 400 to
800 or 800 to 1200 or greater than 1200
square feet then you can set the feature
X I to one of four values right so
there's how you dis precise it comes in
this value feature to discrete value
feature and if you want to apply naive
Bayes to this problem then probably of X
given Y this is just same as before
product from
I equals 1 through n P of XJ given Y
where now this can be a multinomial
probability right where if X now takes
on one of four values say then this can
be estimated a multinomial probably so
instead of a Bernoulli distribution over
to pass all comes this can be a problem
the probably mass function probably over
for most ball comes if you discretize
the size of a Houston to four values and
if you ever discretized variables
typical rule of thumb in machine
learning often we discretize variables
into ten values into 10 buckets that's
just uh it often seems to work well now
I grew four here so I don't to write out
10 buckets but if you ever disguising
their variables you know for most people
will start off with disco sizing things
into 10 down use
No right and so this is how you can
apply now you base other problems as
well including classifying for example
if a house is likely to be sold in make
seventy days now um this there's a
different variation on naivebayes
that I want to describe to you that is
actually much better for the specific
problem of text classification and so a
future representation for X so far was
the following right with a dictionary so
let's see you get an email there's you
know a very spammy email that's drugs by
drugs now this is meant as an
illustrative example I'm not selling any
of my drivers so if if you have a
dictionary of 10,000 words then I guess
let's say a is worth one my pockets were
to just to you know make this example RP
let's say that whereby is worth 800
drugs is the word 1600 and let's say now
is the word is the 6,200 word in your
10,000 words in a sorted dictionary then
the representation for X will be you
know 0 0 right and I put a one there and
one there and the one there okay now one
one so um one interesting thing about
naive Bayes is that it throws away the
fact that the word drug says appear
twice right so that's losing a little
bit of elevation and and in this speaker
representation you know each feature is
either 0 or 1 right and that's part of
why it's throws
way the information that what the one
where drugs appear twice and maybe
should be given more weight for your
classifier um there's a different
representation which is specific to text
and I think text data has a property
that they can be very long or very short
you can have a five-word email or 1,000
word email and somehow you're taking
very strong or very long emails and just
mapping them to a feature vector there's
always the same way just a different
representation for this email which is
for that email this is drills by drugs
and how we're going to represent it as a
four dimensional feature vector so this
is going to be n-dimensional for an
email of length and so rather than a
10,000 dimensional feature vector we now
have a four dimensional feature vector
but now X J is in index from 1 to 10,000
instead of just being 0 or 1 okay and
and this and I guess n varies by chain
example so an eye is the length
of email I say the longer email this
vector the feature vector X will be
longer and if you're short to email this
feature vector will be shorter okay so
let's see just to give names the average
we're going to develop these are these
are really very confusing very horrible
names but this is what the community
calls them the model we've talked about
so far is sometimes called the
multivariate Bernoulli model so
Bernoulli means coin tosses so
multivariate means you know they're ten
thousand Bernoulli random variables in
this model this is a multivariate
Bernoulli event model and the event
comes with statistics and answers and
the new representation we're gonna talk
about is called the multinomial event
model these two names are frankly these
two names are quite confusing but these
are the names that I think actually one
of my friends as McCollum as far as I
know wrote the paper that named these
two algorithms but but I think these are
these are the names me seem to use
and so with this new model
we're gonna build a generative model
because there's a generative model or
model P of X comma Y which can be
factored as follows
and using the naive Bayes assumption
we're going to assume that P of X given
Y is product from I equals 1 through n J
equals 1 to N P of XJ given Y and n
times you know P of Y is that second
term right now one of the one of the
reasons these two models were very
frankly are actually very confusing to
machine learning community it's because
this is exactly the equation that you
know you saw on Monday when we described
naive Bayes for the first time like you
know this P of X in wise father
probabilities is exactly so this this
equation looks cosmetically identical
but with this new model the second model
the confusingly named multinomial event
model the definition of XJ and the
definition of n is very different right
so instead of a product from 1 through
10,000 there's a product from 1 through
the number of words in your email and
this is now instead a multinomial
probability rather than the binary or
Bernoulli probability and it turns out
that with this model the parameters are
same as before if I was very at one
equals one and also the other parameters
of this model by K given y equals zero
is a chance of XJ equals K given y
equals zero right and then just to make
sure you understand the notation
see if this makes sense so this
probability is the chance of word blank
being black if they were y equals zero
so what goes in those two blanks
actually what goes in a second bag let's
see
yes says a chance of the third word in
the email being aware drugs which ones
are the second word in the email being
by or whatever and one part of what
wouldn't firstly assumes me why this is
tricky is that we assume that this
probability doesn't depend on J right
that for every position an email for the
chance of the first word being drugs the
same as chances of second Rabindra to
say mr. worth being drugs which is why
on the left hand side J doesn't actually
appear on the left hand side right any
questions about this and so the way you
calculate the probability the way you
would and so the way that given a new
email a test email you would calculate
this probability is by you know plugging
these parameters a USB from Tainter into
this formula
oh and then no I wrote down and then an
Indian set the parameters is this kind
of just with our y equals one is that y
equals zero and then for the maximum
likely resume the parameters I just
write out one of them your estimate of
the chance of a given work there's
really any word in any position being
word K what's the chance of some word in
a non-spam email being the word drugs
let's say the chance of that is equal to
you I find it well this indicates a
function notation
those are complex I just say in a second
what this actually means
so the denominator so this space means
so if you figure out what the English
meaning of this complicated formula is
this basically says look at all the
words in all of your non-spam emails all
the emails of y equals zero and look at
all of the words in all of the emails
and so all of those words what fraction
of those words is the word drugs and
that's a new estimate of the chance of
the word drugs appearing in the non-spam
email is
position in that right and so in nav the
denominator is sum over your training
set indicator is not spam times the
number of words in that you know
so the denominator ends up being the
total number of words in all of your
non-stemi emails in your training set
and the numerator is some of your
training set some from michaeles wants
um indicator y equals zero so you know
concept only the things for non-spam
email and for the non-spam email J
equals 1 through and I go over the words
in that email and see how many words are
that worth K right and so if in your
training set you have you know a hundred
thousand words in your non-spam emails
and 200 of them are the word drugs the
course you know 200 times then this
range would be two hundred over a
hundred thousand
oh and then lastly to implement Laplace
moving with this you would add one to
the numerator as usual and then let's
see actually what would you add to the
denominator
wait but what is K naught K right K is a
variable it's okay indexes into the
words what you had 1000 oh I think I've
just read why you say K I think over
though the notation when defining the
fast moving I think I use K is the
number of possible outcomes yeah but
here cases in depth yeah right so CI
once a numerator and add the number of
possible outcomes in denominator which
in this case was there at 10,000 so so
this is the probability of X being equal
to the value of K where K ranges from 1
the sooner 10,000 if you have a
dictionary size if you're about a list
of 10,000 words you're modeling and so
the number of possible values for X is
10,000 so you have 10,000 simulator
Oh what do you do worse around in a
dictionary so um there are two
approaches of that one is just throw it
away
just ignore it disregard it that's one
second approach is to take the rare
words and map them to a special token
which traditionally is denoted UNK for
unknown word so if in your training set
you decide to take just the top 10,000
words
it sends your dictionary then everything
that's down the top 10,000 words you can
map to a you know unknown word token
unknown where a special symbol
oh why they wipe their run before oh
this is an indicator function notation
so indicates a function boy so if so
this is this notation right means so
indicator you know two equals one plus
one this is true and indicates her you
know V equals five but this is this is
no formula that's either true or false
did I know whether Y is zero
I guess if Y is 0 1 this is the same as
not why I again saw 1 minus y all right
so I think both event models including
the details of mass molecular estimates
are written out in more detail in
lecture notes um so you know when would
you use the naive Bayes algorithm it
turns out now greens algorithm is
actually not very competitive of other
learning algorithms so for most problems
you find that logistic regression we're
better in terms of delivering a higher
accuracy than naive Bayes but the the
advantages of naive Bayes is first is
completely very efficient and second is
relatively quick to implement right and
it also doesn't require iterative
gradient descent thing and the number of
lines of code needs its employee base is
relatively small so if you are facing a
problem where you go is to implement
something quick and dirty then naive
Bayes is is may be a reasonable choice
and I think you know as you work on your
class projects I think some of you
priority minority will try to invent a
new machine learning algorithm and write
a research paper and and I think you
know inventing new machine learning is a
great thing to do
helps love people on a lot of different
applications so this one
the majority of constructions to t9
won't try to apply a learning algorithm
to a project that you care about we
applied to a research project you're
working on somewhere Stanford or apply
it to a fun application you want to
build or apply to business application
for some of you taking this on SCPD
taking this remotely and if your goal is
not to invent a brand new learning
algorithm but to take the existing
algorithms and apply them then your
thumb I suggest to you is when you get
started on the machine learning project
start by implementing something quick
and dirty
instead of implanting most complicated
possible learning algorithm stop
influencing something quickly and train
the algorithm look at how it performs
and then use that to deep out the
algorithm and keep innovating all right
so I think you know what does a Stanford
so we're very good at coming up with
very very complicated algorithms but if
you go is to make something work for an
application
you brought it and invented neither in
the algorithm and published a paper on a
new technical you know contribution if
you if you mean go is a you're working
on an application on understanding news
better or improving the environment or
estimating prices or whatever and your
primary objective is just make an
algorithm work then rather than building
a very complicated out and if it all set
I would recommend implementing something
quickly so that you can then better
understand how it's performing and then
to error analysis which we'll talk about
later and use that to drive your
development you know one one one analogy
I sometimes make is that if you are
let's see so if you're writing a new
computer program with 10,000 lines of
code right one approach is to write all
10,000 lines of code first and then they
try compiling it for the first time
right and that's clearly a bad idea
and then sudden you know you should
write small Maude use around the
attested unit testing and then build up
the program incremental you rather than
write 10,000 lines of code and then
start to see what syntax errors he gave
me for the first time um and I think a
similar for machine learning instead of
building a very complicated algorithm
from the get-go we've got a simpler
algorithm tested and then and then use
the see what is doing one see what's
doing wrong to improve from there you
often end up getting to a better
performing algorithm faster um so here's
here's one example there's actually
something I used to work on I actually
started on conference on you know and
Auntie spats you know student work on
spam classification many years ago and
it turns out that when you start out on
a new application problem oh it's hard
to know what's the hardest part of the
problem right so if you want to build an
anti-spam crossfire the lots of things
you could work on for example spammers
would deliberately misspell words you
know wallet mortgage that right no
refinance your mortgage or whatever but
instead of writing the words mortgage
the spammers would write them 0 RT GA or
instead of GA keaney maybe uh slash
slash right but all of us as people have
no trouble meaning this is aware
mortgage but this would trip up a spam
filter this might map the work to an
unknown word talk about just Alfred it
hasn't seen this before and does the
line this were to slip by the spam
filter so that's one idea for improving
spam or action one over here see
students the hall like we actually roll
the paper
mapping this back to worse like that so
this dental they can see their words the
way that humans see them all right so
that's one idea
another idea might be a lot of spam
email spruce email headers you know
spammers often tried to hide where the
email truly came from
by spoofing the email header the email
address on from information and and and
another thing you might do is try to
fetch the URLs that are referred to in
the email and then analyze the webpages
that you get to write but a lot of
things that you could do to improve a
spam filter and any one of these topics
could easily be three months or six
months of research but when you're
building say a new spam filter for the
first time how do you actually know
which of these is the best investment of
your time so my advice to those who work
on project if your primary goes just get
distinctive work is to not somewhat
arbitrarily dive in and spend six months
on improving this or spend you know six
plans on trying to analyze email headers
but just that implement a more basic
algorithm almost implement something
quick and dirty and then look at the
examples that your learning algorithm is
still misclassifying if you find that if
after you've implemented a quick and
dirty algorithm you find that yours the
anti-spam algorithm is misclassifying a
lot of examples with these deliberately
misspell words there's only then they
get more evidence than it's worth
spending a bunch of time solving the
misspelled words and deliberately
misspell words problem right but you
implement spam filter and you see that
there's not misclassifying a lot of
examples of these misspelled worst and I
would say don't bother go work on
something else is there or these at
least treat that as a lower priority so
one of the uses of
GDA call centers grant analysis as well
as naive bayes is that is they're not
going to be the most accurate algorithms
if you want the highest precision
accuracy there are other algorithms like
which is you Russian or as well switched
up walnuts or neural networks we talk
about later which will others always
give you higher classification accuracy
than these algorithms but the advantage
of Johnson's analysis and naive Bayes is
that they are very quick to train there
is no literature this is just counting
and GDA is just computing means and
covariances
right so it's very calm
they efficient and also there are there
are simple to implement so it can help
you implement that quick and dirty thing
that helps you get going more quickly
and so I think for your project as well
I would advise most of you to you know
as you start working on your project
I would advise most of you to don't
spend weeks designing exactly what
you're going to do if you have an
advocate if you have your theory of an
apply project but instead get the Dana
said and apply something simple start to
reach a super aggression
noth-nothing your network or not not
something more complicated or started
nowadays and then see how that performs
and then and then go from there okay
alright so that's it for naive Bayes and
generative learning algorithms the thing
I want to do is move on to a different
type of classifier which is a support
vector machine let me check out any
questions about this with Wyman's long
oh wait oh sorry oh can use logistic
regression with discrete variables
oh I see yeah right yes so yes right so
one of the weaknesses of the naive Bayes
algorithm is that it treats all the
words completely you know separate from
each other
so right there was one and two are quite
similar and whereas the only mother and
father are quite similar and so but with
this feature better representation it
doesn't know the relation means these
words so in machine learning there are
other ways of representing words this
technique called word embeddings in
which we choose the feature
representation that encodes the fact
that the worst one and two are quite
similar to each other are the worst
mother and father question as each other
you know they're worse whatever London
and Tokyo are quite suit each other
because they're both city names and so
this is a technique that I was not
planning to teach Europe but that is
taught in CS 2:30 but you can also read
up on word embeddings or look at some of
their videos or reasons from CS 2:30 you
want to so the word embeddings technique
this is a technique from neural networks
really will reduce the number of
training examples you need to learn a
good tech sauce fire because it comes in
with more knowledge victim by the way I
do this in the other classes too inside
the other classes something got a
question I go no we don't do that we
just covered as ICSC jt9 so
actually ICS 224 and I think also covers
this yeah the NLP appreciate yeah I'm
sure okay so so support vector machine
says be ins um let's see the
classification problem right whether
they said looks like this and so you
want an algorithm to find you know like
a non linear decision boundary right so
the support vector machine will be an
algorithm to help us find potentially
very very nonlinear decision boundary is
like this now one way to build a
classifier like this would be to use
logistic regression but if this is X 1
this is X 2 right
so the logistic regression will fit a
straight line to Zeta a Gaussian
distribution Valerie so one way to apply
this is arrested like this would be to
take your feature vector x1 x2 and map
it to a high dimensional feature vector
with you know x1 x2 x1 squared x2
squared x1 x2 may be X Y cube x2 cube
and so on and have a new feature vector
which we'll call the value of x that
that has these high dimensional features
right now it turns out if you do this
and then apply logistic regression to
this augmented feature vector then
logistic regression can learn nonlinear
decision boundaries with this other
features
there's just regression if you actually
learn the decision boundary there's this
there's a shape of an ellipse but man
they'll be choosing these features is a
little bit of a pain right
know what I did I actually don't know
what you know type of all set of
features could get you a decision valve
you like that right rather than just in
the lips and more complex is your mouth
to me and what we will see with support
vector machines is that we will be able
to derive an algorithm that can take say
input features x1 x2 map them to a much
higher dimensional set of features and
then apply a linear classifier in a way
similar to logistic regression but
different in details that allows you to
learn very nonlinear decision boundaries
and I think you know a support vector
machine one of the actually one of the
reasons support vector machines are used
today is is a relatively turnkey
algorithm and what I mean by that is it
doesn't have too many parameters to
fiddle with even for logistic regression
or for linear regression you know you
might have to tune the gradient descent
parameter a tune the learning rate sorry
change the learning rate alpha and
that's just another thing that fiddle
worked very try a few values and hope
you didn't mess up how you said that
value Oh a support vector machine today
has the very robust very mature software
packages they can just download to train
a support vector machine on on any on
you know on a problem and you just run
it and the algorithm will kind of
converge without you having to worry too
much about the details so I think on the
grand scheme of things today I would say
support vector machines are not as
effective as neural networks for many
problems but but one dream propria
support vector machines is this is
turnkey you kind of just turn the key
and it works and there isn't as many
parameters like the learning rate and
other things that you have to fiddle
with
so the roadmap is we're going to develop
the following set of ideas talk about
the optimal margin classifier today and
we'll start with the separable case and
what that means is going to start off
with data sets that we assume look like
this and that are linearly separable and
so the also margin classifier is the
basic building block of a support vector
machine and will first derive an
algorithm
don't be they'll have some similarities
to a logistic regression but that allows
us a scale in the important way it's
that to find a linear classifier for
training cells like this that we assume
for now can be linearly separated so
we'll do that today and then what you
see on Wednesday is excuse me next
Monday
wait you see next Monday is an idea
called kernels and the kernel idea is
one of the most powerful ideas in
machine learning is how do you take a
feature vector X maybe this is r2 and
map it too much high dimensional set of
features in our example there that was
our 5 right and then train an algorithm
on this higher dimensional set of
features and and the cool thing about
kernels is that this high dimensional
set of features may not be r5 it might
be our 100,000 or it might even be our
infinite and so with the kernel
formulation we really take you know the
original set of features that you were
given for the houses you trying to sell
you know medical conditions try to
predict and map this two dimensional
feature vector space into maybe an
infinite dimensional
so the features and what this does is it
relieves us from a lot of the burden of
manually picking features right like do
you want to have square root of x 1 or
maybe X 1 X 2 to the power of 2/3 so you
just don't have the fiddle of these
features too much because the kernels
will allow you to choose an infinitely
large set of features okay and then
finally we'll talk about the inseparable
case so I'm gonna do this today and then
this next Monday so
and by the way I you know the machine
there in the world's become a little
it's funny I think the if you leap well
in the news the media talks a lot about
machine learning the media just talks
about you know neural networks all the
time right and you hear about neural
networks and deep learning wrote the
later in this class but if you look at
what actually happens in practice in
machine learning the set of algorithms
actually used in practice it's actually
much wider than neural networks and deep
learning so so we do not live in a
neural networks only world we actually
use many many tools in machine learning
it's just that deep learning attracts
the attention of the media in some this
in some way there's quite
disproportionate to what I find useful
you know that's like I love them but but
they're not they're not the only thing
in the world
and so yeah late last night I was
talking an engineer about factor
analysis which you learn about latency
s39 right unsupervised learning
algorithm and there's an application
that one of my teams is working on in
manufacturing where I'm gonna use factor
analysis or something very similar to it
which which is totally not a neural
network technique right for so they're
there all these other technique is that
including support vector machines in
ninety days and I think do can use are
not important all right so let's start
developing the optimal margin classifier
so um first let me define the functional
margin which is informally the
functional margin of the classifier is
how well how confident I and accurately
do you classify an example
so here's what I mean we're gonna go to
binary classification and we're gonna
use logistic regression right so so
let's start by motivating this with
logistic regression so deserve which is
a classifier H of theta equals the
logistic function applied to theta
transpose X and so if you turn this into
a binary classification if you have this
algorithm predict not a probability but
predict 0 or 1 then what does classifier
will do is predict 1 if theta transpose
X is greater than 0 right and predict 0
otherwise okay because theta transpose X
is greater than 0 this means that G of
theta transpose X is greater than 0.5
you can I've created emigrate to them an
equal to it doesn't matter yes and
exactly 0.5 it doesn't really matter
what you do
and so you predict 1 if theta transpose
X is greater than equals 0 meaning that
all probability the estimator probably
over cause being 1 is greater than 50/50
and so you predict 1 and if theta
transpose X is less than 0 then you
predict that this class is 0 ok so this
is what happen if you have largest
regression output 1 or 0 rather than
output or probability so in other words
this means that if Y I is equal to 1
right then hope or we want that theta
transpose X alright it's much greater
than 0 this double greater-than sign it
means much greater right because if the
true label is 1 then if the album is
doing well hopefully theta transpose X
right will be faster there right so the
output probability is very very close to
and if indeed theta transpose X is much
greater than zero then G of theta
transpose X will be very close to one
which means that is giving a very good
very accurate prediction very correct
and confident prediction right there
goes one and if Y is equal to zero then
what we want or what we hope is that
theta transpose X I is much less than
zero right because if this is true then
the algorithm is doing very well on this
example so um so the functional margin
which will define in a second captures
this idea that if the Kasbah has a large
functional margin it means that these
two statements are true
um it's a local henro bit there's a
different thing we define in a second
there's the counted geometric margin and
that's the following and for now let's
assume the data is linearly separable
so let's say that's the data set now
that seems like a pretty good decision
boundary for separating the positive and
negative examples
that's another decision boundary in red
that also separates a positive negative
examples but somehow the Green Line
looks much better than the red line so
why is that well the red line comes
really close it's a few of the training
examples whereas the Green Line you know
has a much bigger separation right just
as a much bigger distance from the
positive a negative example so even
though the red line and the Green Line
both you know perfectly separate the
positive and negative examples the Green
Line has a much bigger separation which
is called the geometric margin there's a
much bigger geometric margin meaning of
physical separation from the training
examples even as it separates them okay
and so what I'd like to do in mix
several I guess with next 20 minutes is
formalize definitely functional margin
and formalized definition of geometric
margin and it will pose that I guess the
optimizing classifier which is based in
algorithm that tries to maximize the
geometric margin so what the rudimentary
SVM does what the Hesby mlo dimensional
spaces will do also called the optimal
margin classifier is pose an
optimization problem to try to find a
green line to classify these examples so
now in order to develop svms I'm going
to change the notation a little bit
again yeah because these algorithms have
different properties using slightly
different notation to strive to make
something math-amazing so when
developing SVM's we're going to use
minus 1 and plus 1 to denote the cost
labels
and we're going to have output so rather
than having hypothesis output a
probability like you saw in logistic
regression the support vector machine
will output either minus 1 or plus 1 and
so G of Z becomes minus 1 or 1 so I'll
put 1 if Z is greater than equal to 0
and minus 1 otherwise so instead of a
smooth transition from 0 to 1 we have a
hard transition an abrupt transition
from negative 1 to plus 1
and finally where previously we had for
logistic regression right where this was
our n plus 1 with x0 equals 1 for the
SVM we will have h of just write this
out so for the SVM the parameters of the
SVM will be the parameters W and B and
hypothesis applied to X will be G of
this and we're dropping the X 0 equals 1
constraint so separate out W and B as
follows so this is a standard notation
used to develop support vector machines
and one way to think about this is this
if the parameters are you know theta 0
theta 1 theta 2 theta 3 then this is a
new B and this isn't UW
so you just separate out the theta 0
which is previously Mouse playing to n 0
and so on and so this term here becomes
sum from I equals 1 through n WI x pi
plus b right super conservative x 0
all right so let me formalize the
definition of a functional question so
so the parameters W and B to find a
linear classifier right so you know what
the form is just wrote down the
parameters W and P defines a really
defines a hyperplane but defines a line
or in high dimensions it be a plane or a
hyperplane but defines a straight line
stepping out the positive and negative
examples and so we're gonna say the
functional margin so function margin of
a hyperplane defined by this with
respect to one training example we're
going to write as this and hyperplane
just means straight line right but in
high dimension so this linear classifier
so it's just you know functional margin
of this classifier respect to one
training example we're going to define
as this and so if you compare this with
the equations we had up there you know
if y equals one we hope for that at y
equals zero we hope for that so really
what we hope for is for a classifier to
achieve a large functional margin right
and so so if y I equals 1 then what we
want or what we hope for is that ee
transpose X I plus B is greater than my
creatinine 0 and after they both equal
to minus 1
then we once I'll be hope that this is
much smaller than zero and if you kind
of combine these two statements if you
take why I write and multiply it with
that then you know these two statements
together is basically saying that you
hope that gamma hat I is much greater
than 0 because Y I know is plus 1 or
minus 1 and and so Y is equal to 1 you
want this to be very very large if Y is
negative 1 you want this to be a very
very large negative number and so either
way it's just saying that you hope this
would be very large so we just hope that
and and as an aside one property of this
as well is that so long as gamma hat is
greater than 0 that means the algorithm
so so so long as the functional margin
so long as this gamma hat is greater
than 0 it means that either this is
bigger than 0 this is less than 0
depending on the sign of the label and
it means that the algorithm yes
this one example corrector is right and
much greater than 0 then it means you
know so the scaling Zira means in in the
logistic regression case it means that
the prediction is at least a little bit
above 0.5 and low Pitbull 0.5 probably
at least gets it right and it was much
greater than 0 much less than 0 and
Jesus you know the probability output in
the loose aggression cases are very
close to one or very close to zero so
one of the definition I'm going to
define functional margin respect to the
training set to be gamma hat equals min
over I here R equals ranges over your
training examples okay so this is a
worst-case notion but so this definition
of a function margin on the Left we
define functional margin respect to a
single training example which is how are
you doing on that one training example
and we'll define the function margin
with respect to the entire training set
as how are you doing on the worst
example in your training set this is a
little bit of a brittle notion and we're
for now for today we're assuming that
the training set is linearly separable
so I'm gonna assume that the training
set you know it looks like this and
separative of a straight line or the
Laxus later but because we're assuming
just for today that the training set is
linearly separable we'll use this kind
of worst-case notion and defined the
function margin to be the function
margin of the worst training example
now one thing about the definition of
the functional margin is they're
actually really easy to cheat and
increase the functional margin right and
one thing you can do is look at this
formula is if you take W you know and
multiply it by two and take B and
multiply by two then everything here
just multiplies by two and you've
doubled the functional margin right but
you haven't actually changed anything
meaningful okay so so one one way to
cheat on the functional margin is just
by scaling the parameters by two or in
seven - maybe you can multiply all your
parameters by ten and then you've
actually increased the functional margin
of your training examples 10x but this
doesn't actually change the decision
boundary right it doesn't actually
change any classification just to
multiply all of your parameters by a
factor of ten um so one thing you could
do is replace one thing you could do
would be to normalize the length of your
parameters so for example hypothetically
you can impose a constraint the normal W
is equal to one another way to do that
we could see W and E and replace it with
W over right justify your parameters
through by the magnitude by their by the
Euclidean length of the parameter vector
W and this doesn't change any
classification is just V scaling the
parameters but but but it prevents you
know this way of cheating on the focused
on margin okay and in fact more
generally you could actually scale W and
V by any other value you want and it
doesn't doesn't matter
could choose certain places by w over 17
and then P over 17 before any other very
right and the classification stayed the
same
okay so we'll come back and use this
property all right so to find a
functional margin let's define the
geometric margin and you see in a second
how did your metric on the function
margin relate to each other um so
there's less let's define the geometric
margin with respect to a single example
which is um so let's see let's say you
have a classifier right so given
parameters W and V that defines a linear
classifier and the equation W X plus B
equals zero defines the equation of a
straight line so the axis here I think's
more than x2 and then half of this plane
you know in this half of the plane you
have W transpose X plus B is greater
than 0 and in this half you have W
transpose X plus B is less than 0 and in
between this straight line but given by
this equation W transpose X plus B
equals 0 right and so given parameters W
and B the upper right is where your
classifier will predict y equals 1 and
the lower left is well predict y is
equal to negative 1 ok now let's say you
have a one training example here so
that's a training example X I comma Y I
and that say is a positive example ok
and so your classifier is cause find
this example correctly right because and
the upper right half plane you're in
this half plane double transpose X plus
B is greater than 0 and so
this upper-right region your classifier
is predicting +1 right where is it this
low hot region it be predicting H of X
equals negative 1 and that's why this
straight line where switches from
predicting negative to positive is the
decision boundary so what we're going to
do is define this distance to be the
geometric margin of this training
example it's that you couldn't distance
is what we're define to be the geometric
immersion so let me just write down what
that is
so the geometric margin
you know the classifier of the hyper
plane defined by WB we respect to one
example X my eye this is going to be
gamourai equals and let's see I'm not
proving why this is the case the proof
is given an election notes but the
legend else shows why this is the right
formula for measuring the Euclidean
distance that I just drew a picture up
there okay but then I'm not proving this
here but the proof is giving election
that was me this turns out to be the way
you compute the Euclidean distance
between you have an example and in the
decision boundary okay um and and and
this is for the positive example I guess
more generally going to define the
geometric margin to be equal to this and
this definition applies to positive
examples and to negative examples and so
the relationship between the geometric
margin and the functional margin is that
the geometric margin is equals in a
personal margin divided by the norm of W
finally the geometric margin with
respect to the training set is we're
gain use this worst-case notion look
through all your training examples and
pick the worst possible training example
and that is your geometric margin on the
training set
oh and and so I hope that certain
notation is clear right so gamma hat was
the functional margin and gamma is a
geometric margin and so
what the optimal margin classifier does
is choose the parameters W and B to
maximize the geometric margin okay so in
other words this is the optimal margin
classifiers it's the baby SVM
SVM for linearly separable call data at
least for today
so the optimum arching crossfire would
choose that straight line because that
straight line maximizes the distance or
maximizes the geometric margin so all of
these examples know oh how you pose this
mathematically they're few steps of this
derivation I don't want to do but I'll
just describe the beginning step and the
last step and leave that in the in
between steps the lecture notes
but it turns out that one way to pose
this problem is to maximize gamma W and
B of gamma so you want to maximize the
geometric margin subject to that subject
to that every training example must have
geometric margin greater than or equal
to gamma right so you want gamma to
means bigger possible subject to that
every single training example must have
at least as I mentioned
this causes you to maximize the
worst-case geometric motion and it turns
out this is um not in this form this
isn't a convex optimization problem so
it's difficult to solve this without
don't like green design initially
there's no little glassware and so on
but it turns out that by a few steps are
be writing you can reformulate this
problem as into the equivalent problem
which is a minimizing normal W subject
to the dramatic margin and so it turns
out so I hope this problem makes sense
right so this problem is just you know
solve for W and B to make sure that
every example test your metric margin
creating equal gamma and you want gather
to be as big as possible
so this is a way to find the
optimization problem that says maximize
the geometric margin and what we show in
the lecture notes is that through a few
steps you can rewrite this optimization
problem into the following equivalent
form which is to try to minimize the
normal W subject to this and maybe one
piece of intuition to take away is you
know the smaller W is the bigger right
the less of a normalization Division
effect you have right but the details
are given in lecture notes ok but this
turns out to be a convex optimization
problem and if you optimize this then
you will have the optimal margin
classifier and they're very good
numerical optimization packages to solve
this optimization problem and if you
give this a data set then you know
assuming your data is separable we'll
fix that assumption well reconvene next
week then you have the optimal knowledge
and classifier where should be the baby
svf and we add kernels to it then you
have the full content of C
alright let's break for the day
see see you guys